riot games has been cooking once again
over the last year we've gotten a ton of
teasers about their upcoming 2D fighter
project L but just last week we got the
most significant content drop yet on top
of all the new gameplay mechanics a ton
of fgc members have gotten significant
time with the game to test it out and
share their thoughts and honestly this
game is shaping up to be pretty damn
good but it also might change the
competitive fighting game landscape
forever
[Music]
foreign
just another one of the FPS guys around
here but I'll have you know I'm bad at
so many other types of games too
especially Fighters anyway over the last
year we've gotten a pretty slow drip
feed of information about riots in
development fighter code named project L
now what we already knew is that it's a
tag based fighter set in the League of
Legends universe and is being developed
by some ogs in the fgc but last week
Riot dropped some videos that gave us
way more details about the game
including footage of full matches the
biggest piece of news is that project L
isn't just a Marvel V Capcom style tag
team versus fighter but one with a 2v2
team mode this means that teams of two
players can face off together in the
same match with each player piloting a
single Champion so we're building a game
where you can play it with your friends
as well as against them games like
Street Fighter cross Tekken have had
four player tag game modes in the past
but it's never been done for a versus
game like project out all basically just
like in regular 1v1 matches each team
gets two Champions the difference in
this game mode is that each Champion is
controlled by a separate player the
active player chooses when to tag in
their partner but the player on the
sidelines is the one who chooses when to
use their assist moves this means
communication is going to be super
important for success in Project L which
is a skill that's never really been
tested in fighting games before the
person who's not playing controls the
the verse so there's moments where I was
playing with someone and I was I'm not
going to name names but I'm elbowing
them over and over like hey I'm getting
hit please burst please save me burst
burst remola burst and she like you know
she didn't do it the other major new
mechanic that Ryan showed off is the
fuse system fuses allow you to select a
buff that you and your partner can then
take into a match some provide
straightforward damage Buffs While
others give you access to new mechanics
like back-to-back supers now fuses
aren't a brand new idea they have a lot
of similarities to Street Fighter cross
tekken's gem system and grooves from
Capcom vs snk2 the point is for the most
part fuses give you access to these
similar mechanics found in other versus
games for example those back-to-back
supers are just delayed hyper combos
from Marvel vs Capcom but having access
to a specific fuse at a certain moment
could completely change the way you play
the game and hopefully in the future it
leads to massive differences between
team compositions and already so far
we've seen four different fuses double
down which lets you do those
back-to-back supers 2x assist which lets
your teammate act twice every time you
call them Fury which gives you a damage
boost on low health and freestyle which
lets you tag out a character twice per
combo instead of just once the devs
suggests that there will be many more in
the future and experimenting with
different combinations of fuses and
teams can unlock new depths to the game
there we go
next to all that Riot also let several
pros and content creators get their
hands on the game for a couple days left
in Justin Wong Maximilian dude and
plenty more were given access to the
game to make content and generally just
try to break it and so far their
reactions have been pretty damn positive
I can't wait for what this does to the
fighting game community
I'm so so excited I think this game
would have been a must play for most
people even if it was just you know a
basic game that no one really was that
excited about but the fact that it's
this good already
in this limited form and that it's so
complex it's so interesting and this
here was the moment that many hardcore
fighting game fans were waiting for yes
project L is being made by long-standing
members of the community but the more
people that get their hands on the game
the more information we get which is a
lot more than we would from just
scrolling through a riot video for
example one of the things the devs
didn't focus on a whole lot in this
video is movement it turns out that with
its air dashes super jumps and wave
dashing fluid movement is one of if not
the biggest highlight from the game so
far and yes there is a dash macro so if
you're looking for easy movement the
game's movement won't be Troublesome yet
it'll be very strong the game's all
about movement so that's really good
okay although it is still very early it
does seem like project L is shaping up
to be damn good fun at least in my
opinion but since this is Riot I suspect
that they want project L to be a lot
more than just a fun game to play with
friends and it's aside from all the new
info the devs also sort of touched on
things like playing the game on stage or
at the competitive level they even
announced that a playable demo is going
to be available to the public at Evo in
Las Vegas now there was no doubt in my
mind that Riot was going to want to
pursue this game as an esport but this
all but confirmed it
the question is what do they want that
esport to look like for starters is
competitive play going to focus on 2v2
or 1v1 although 1v1 might be the more
traditional game mode when people think
of fighting games Wright is clearly
putting a lot of marketing towards 2v2
and when they brought together all these
creators and Pros for this play test
that's the game mode they were playing
on top of that there's pretty much no
2v2 games in the competitive scene right
now so this could be Riot's way of
differentiating themselves from the pack
while still creating a team-based esport
in the process my guess is that at least
when it comes to the esport ride is
going to test out both 1v1 and 2v2
what's going to be interesting is seeing
which one becomes more popular now aside
from that how is Riot actually going to
run this thing once they get it started
because the answer might not be that
straightforward you see Riot has a ton
of money and they've proved in the past
that they actually care about developing
and maintaining healthy Esports scenes
for their games and although valran did
start with some community events Ryan
now operates that scene with the same
level of centralized control as they do
with League of Legends in contrast the
fgc has historically been rooted in
community events and independent
tournaments and this Independence has
kept the fgc stable as opposed to
relying on dev support that could
potentially disappear at any moment now
this also means that there's a lot less
money in fighting games I mean don't get
me wrong there are some events with
massive amounts of cash behind them but
none of it compares to the funds Riot
has access to when it comes to their
events they're simply on another level
so the question is does ride want
project L to just slot into the existing
landscape of the fgc or do they want to
take over and control everything in my
opinion I think they're going to at
least try to maintain a healthy balance
between both at least at the start after
all the two guys that are in charge of
project L are the same dudes who founded
Evo so I find it unlikely that they'd
let Riot take over the fgc with this
game listen the fgc has a long running
fear of devs exercising a bit too much
control over their scene people feel
very strongly about keeping things
Grassroots and they usually only reach
out to the devs when they need some
money kicked into the prize pool but
with project L being made by people that
have been connected to the scene for so
long I have high hopes that they're
going to stay true to the core values of
the fgc and potentially bring the genre
to an even wider audience
someone tweeted the other to say what's
the perfect esport and most people said
CS
but I think it's fighting games I think
if you were to sell
people on Esports that is the way you
sell it is with fighting games
personally like if I were to show my
parents
they'd be like I don't know what the
is going on in valorent I don't
know what's going on the league but if I
showed them
a fighting game
they would it would click for them I
think